Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a post apocalyptic drama film
called “Cargo”. Watch out and take care!
At the start of the film, we
are introduced to a couple,
Andy and Kay, along with their one-year-old
daughter Rosie. In a world ravaged by a virus
that turns people into zombies in 48 hours, they
seek refuge on a houseboat in rural Australia.
While relocating to a safe place for the night,
Andy spots two children playing on the riverside.
He waves at them and tries to talk with
them, but their father spots Andy and draws
a revolver from his belt, compelling him
to continue on his way. The family is used
to getting supplies from the sea as they are
too scared of travelling to the land. Later,
Kay mentions that their food supplies are running
out and that they should travel through land to
get better supplies. However, Andy criticizes her
decision as he is scared of what lies on land.
Afterward, Andy discovers an abandoned sailboat
on the riverbank, and goes out to inspect it.
While he collects some food and a bottle of
wine from inside, he hears some strange noises
coming from within a door. Despite being curious,
Andy is unwilling to take any risks and retreats
to his boat. He passes the captured goods over
to Kay, but she is skeptical about the food.
Being the good husband that he is, Andy manages
to convince his wife that everything is fine.
Later, Kay asks Andy to take a break and then
heads to the sailboat. The greed to salvage
more supplies prompts her to enter the dangerous
yacht alone. Andy had left earlier after hearing
thuds from a wall door, but Kay is completely
unaware of this. Soon, she gets pulled and bitten
by an unknown entity, most likely a zombie.
Andy's sleep is disturbed by Rosie's crying and he
goes in search of Kay. He notices some bloodstains
on the floor and finds Kay trying to keep blood
flow under control. She is inside the restroom and
has a bite mark on her knee. She then explores a
rucksack that Andy had retrieved from the yacht
earlier. Kay wears a bracelet that counts down
how much longer an infected has left, as well
as an infusion that mitigates the brain and
allows an infected to transition into a zombie
painlessly. Andy and Kay discuss their objectives,
revealing Kay's vulnerabilities to the
family. After the emotional discussion,
the family finally makes the decision to leave
the houseboat and seek medical assistance.
In the next scene, Thoomi, a little Aboriginal
girl, is shown doodling in a sketchbook.
After leaving her house, she tosses a dead rabbit
into a hole. She suddenly hears gurgling noises
and puts her hands over her ears. It seems
like she is trying to feed something.
Later, Andy and Kay locate a car nearby. They
nearly dodge a zombie approaching them as
they drive away. After some time driving,
they take a halt where Andy studies a map
as Kay starts changing Rosie's diaper. Just then,
Kay drops on the floor vomiting blood all over.
Andy jumps out of the car and swiftly calms
her down. Kay appears to be transforming into
a zombie. On the other hand, Thoomi can be
seen throwing a snake into the hole again,
but this time she hears no sound.
Elsewhere, Kay regains her consciousness
and examines her wound, which is dripping
yellow sludge. She screams at Andy as she
gets out of the car, outraged that he has been
trying to keep her zombie progress secret from
her. She's worried about infecting their baby
daughter. Despite his concerns, Andy calms her and
persuades her to follow him. To prevent Kay from
making another escape, he smashes the doorknob.
On the way, Andy gets distracted by a weird
looking guy on the road, which results in
the car crashing onto a tree. Hours later, Andy
regains consciousness and tries to wake Kay up,
but finds her already turned into a zombie. Her
lips and eyes are all filled with yellow pus. Andy
is frightened and tries to escape with Rosie, but
gets bitten by her while attempting to do so.
After some attempts, Andy manages to get out of
the car and applies one of the injections to Kay.
Before setting out towards the destination on
foot, he puts Kay’s timer bracelet on himself
and straps Rosie to his back. The small girl
starts crying as she misses her mother but Andy
quickly calms her down by applying Kay's perfume.
During a short stop for rest, Andy discovers the
person who caused their accident. He identifies
him as a zombie and prepares to defend himself.
Suddenly, Thoomi appears and attempts to
distract the zombie guy, who turns out to
be her father. She requests Andy to remain
away from him and cuts her hand with a rock,
which starts dripping blood. This seems to
attract her zombie father towards her.
After some walking, Andy enters a school and
encounters a retired instructor named Etta.
She aids him in washing his wounds and informs him
that all of the Aboriginal people in the area have
left, including many of her former students.
She also requests him to spend the night at
the school. Later, Andy notices a fire nearby
started by the Aboriginals and also a woman who
is trying to contact Thoomi. At night, Andy gets
his first seizure because of the zombie effect.
He begins to vomit blood and passes out.
The next morning, he wakes up and walks
outside to meet Etta, who urges him
to look for Thoomi's father, Willie,
as he will look over Rosie. She then advices Andy
to be away from the Aboriginals as they murder
any zombies or infected who come near them. After
the conversation, Andy heads out once again.
On the way, Andy pauses at some ruins
to give Rosie water. As he rushes out,
he passes several zombies with their heads
buried in the ground. One of them rises and
starts pursuing him. Andy finds a car and tries
to steal it, but is stopped by a guy named Vic,
who protects him from the zombie who had been
following him. Vic is stuck beneath a tank,
and he hands up the car keys to Andy in exchange
for a promise that he will save him first.
Andy agrees right away, and after removing
the weight that had been squeezing Vic ,he
starts the car. The two then rush into their
car and race away, leaving the zombies.
In the following scene, Vic drives Andy to his
sanctuary, which was originally a gas plant
outpost, where he used to work. Lorraine, Vic's
wife, is quietly surprised to meet Andy. Vic then
instructs Andy to leave Rosie with Lorraine so
the two men can work together for hunting some
food and killing zombies. Vic believes that once
the country is back to normal, people will crave
money again, thus his job is killing groups
of zombies and seizing their belongings.
Vic baits the zombies by putting healthy,
live individuals in cages. Meanwhile,
Andy notices Vic holding Thoomi hostage inside
a cage, and gets irritated. Inside the shelter,
while Lorraine is looking after Rosie and
attempting to cheer her up, she discovers
some yellow slime-like thing on her belly.
Vic and Andy, on the other hand, move to a
different cage. He uses organs, a radio, and blood
to attract zombies, which makes Andy doubt himself
for a bit. After the boys return to the shelter,
Lorraine discusses cleaning up Rosie briefly.
As Andy plays with his daughter before putting her
in a temporary cradle, his hand starts to twitch.
Seeing himself in this terrible condition and
knowing that Rosie is in safe hands, Andy comes
outside the shelter to a lonely place and tries
to kill himself. But before he is able to do so,
Lorraine confronts him and explains that
she is not Vic's wife and that Vic rescued
himself by allowing her husband and other gas
plant workers to die. As they are conversing,
Vic appears out of nowhere and uses the
butt of his rifle to knock Andy down.
When Andy wakes up, he finds himself in the
same cage as Thoomi. Andy then asks Thoomi
to help him to get out of the cage. He devises a
strategy in which he connects raw guts to a rope,
attracting a swarm of zombies. When the zombies
begin to tug on the rope, the door opens,
allowing the two to flee. They safely return to
the shelter and persuade Lorraine to come along
with them. As they try to escape, Vic emerges and
starts shooting at them. Lorraines shows herself
and attempts to stop him but it's too late
as Vic accidentally shoots her dead.
Andy follows Thoomi to the cage he saw before,
but the man inside has vanished. They manage
to avoid Vic's pursuit and spend the night in a
tiny gorge. After freeing each other's chains,
they sleep freely. Later at night, Thoomi wakes
up to heavy breathing and hides with Rosie as Andy
rubs his face against blood on the wall.
The next morning, Andy and Thoomi have a talk
regarding her father's well-being. After Andy
points out that her father may never get well,
Thoomi storms away in anger. Just then, Thoomi
discovers her father straddling on the tree,
dead. Andy arrives to console Thoomi, but fails
and swiftly departs. Soon, he has another nervous
breakdown after he finds out that he has very
little time left before he completely transforms
into a zombie. After some time, he attempts to
bury his head in the earth like other zombies.
Thoomi stands by the tree, heartbroken, but
hears Rosie's cry and rushes to her aid. When
Andy wakes up, he is surprised by Thoomi, who has
chosen to assist him in reaching the river.
In the next scene, they travel by motorboat to
the campground where Andy last saw the family
playing. They find an RV and investigate it but
find it empty. After that, Andy and Rosie search
for the family, while Thoomi stays behind. Andy
finally meets the father, but finds out that he
has been infected from a zombie attack. For the
second time, the man shows Andy his loaded rifle.
The man then reveals that there are six bullets in
there, two of which Andy may retain after he uses
the rest on himself and his family. Andy tries
to persuade the man from finishing his family,
but he fails. While Andy is leaving, four
gunshots can be heard in the distance.
He flinches at the sound of each of them. After
the whole family is dead, Andy takes the gun and
considers whether or not to shoot himself. As Andy
is contemplating, Thoomi appears out of nowhere,
announcing that she is ready to return to her
home. She also suggests Andy follow her so
that he can leave Rosie with the aboriginals.
Following this, they set out together to look
for smoke coming from a nearby hill.
As they pass through the train tunnel,
Vic emerges in front of them. Thoomi hides
with Rosie inside a parked truck on the tracks
as Andy attempts to distract Vic. Andy shoots
rounds but misses each time as the two guys
become more violent. Vic emerges from the shadows
after the brawl and drags Thoomi from the truck.
He then knocks her head on the rails. While Thoomi
lies in agony, Vic grabs hold of Rosie. A limping
Andy gets up to check on Thoomi, who is still
alive. He then finds Vic cradling with Rosie.
He sits near Vic and demands his daughter back.
At first Vic refuses but he ultimately returns
the child while mourning Lorraine's untimely
death. The trio then continue their journey.
Continuing their way towards the destination,
Andy begins to transform into a zombie.
With very little time left, Andy begs
Thoomi to promise to look for Rosie,
with whom he exchanges a goodbye. Fearing that
he might harm someone, Andy covers his mouth with
a guard. He then starts securing his wrists, and
wraps the meat from earlier on a stick. Suddenly,
his eyelashes are sealed shut and he passes
out. Andy has now turned into a zombie and all
his emotions have died. Despite this, he still
carries the two children on his back, as he is
drawn in by the chunk of flesh on the stick.
Eventually, they arrive at the Aboroginal's camp.
The warriors seize Andy, while Thoomi and Rosie
are hailed by her mother. One of the warriors is
about to strike Andy with his spear but Thoomi
intervenes. She then takes Kay's perfume bottle
and gives it one final spritz. Andy is briefly
brought back to awareness by the aroma,
which reminds him that Rosie is now in safe hands.
Following that, Thoomi ultimately allows the
warrior to put Andy out of his misery.
In the final scene, The Aboriginal people
are shown traveling to a shelter, where they are
received warmly by several members of their tribe.
Rosie is being examined by Thoomi and her
mother when they see the words Thank You
scrawled in white paint on her tummy.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help the
channel out. Thank You for watching.